good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about five ways that you
can attract success my favorite part is
the Y clip and I'm curious I figure out
which one you guys like the best
basically the message of the secret is
the message that I've been trying to
share with the world on my show for the
past 21 years the messages that you're
really responsible for your life you are
responsible for your life I've known
this I've known this since the color
purple in 1985 have probably told you
the story when I do the color purple but
in 1985 I did the color purple prior to
that I had read the book Larry this is a
this is when I've got the secret thing
but I didn't know it was called the
secret I read the book the color purple
and then went out and got books for
everybody else I knew and I was obsessed
about this story obsessed about it I ate
slept thought all the time about the
color purple I moved to Chicago I get a
call from a casting agent asking what I
like to come an audition for a movie
I've never gotten a call in my life from
anybody for a movie or anything like
that and I say is it the color purple
and he says no it's a movie called
moonsong and I go well I've been praying
for the color purple and I go to the
audition and of course it was the color
purple I audition I don't hear anything
for months and I go to this this fat
farm and I think it's because I'm fat
because I was about 212 pounds at the
time and I think I didn't get the call
back because I'm so fat and I'm at this
fat farm and I'm praying and crying
saying to God help me let this go
because I wanted to be in this movie so
much I wanted that I wanted I wanted it
I thought I was going to be in the movie
there's all these signs that I should be
in the movie and I go to this fat farm
and I'm praying and crying and as I'm on
the track singing this song I surrender
I surrender all all to thee my blessed
Savior I surrender all I'm singing that
song praying and crying a woman comes
out to me and she says on the track it's
raining and she says there's a phone
call for you
and the phone call was Steven Spielberg
saying I want to see you in my office in
California tomorrow now what I learned
from that at that moment absolutely
changed my life forever
because I had drawn the color purple
into my life I didn't know Steven
Spielberg I didn't know Quincy Jones who
saw me in Chicago in 1984 he was he was
there for a lawsuit that was being filed
against Michael Jackson because he'd
been working on his his Thriller album
and he saw me on am Chicago and said
that's Sophia now I didn't know him I
didn't know anybody that had anything to
do with that but I knew that I had drawn
that into my life and it changed the way
I thought about my life forever so
you're not surprised at the success of
the secret I am I'm thrilled for that
the success of the secret I think that
the message needs to go further because
I think the mistake that was made with
the secret is that they tried to they
don't know they that they tried to let
that be the answer to all questions it's
not that it's just one law the law of
attraction is one law there are many
laws working in the world but it is very
true that the way you think creates
reality for yourself there are other
factors going on so it's not everything
but you really can't change your own
reality based on the way that you think
Oh
obviously you knew somewhere inside
yourself that you were destined to be
famous because I think it's really a
marvelous thing that visualization thing
you did you don't do I read about this I
hear this that you used to go up on
Mulholland Drive and play every night
and visualize seeing yourself is yeah I
would visualize uh yeah this relies
broken poor right having directors
interested in me and people that I
respected saying you know I like your
work whenever that is and and I would
visualize things coming to me that I
wanted or whatever this was in like
nineteen eighty seven eighty five yeah
and I had nothing at that time so it was
like it but it just made me feel better
it made me at that time all it really
was for me was kind of making me feel
better I would drive home and think well
I do have these things and they're out
there I just don't have a hold of them
yet but they're out there okay so you
would get this from what self-help books
or whatever yeah uh-huh self-help
section self-help section they've
renamed it the Jim Carrey wing so didn't
you write yourself a check I heard that
you did is that true wrote myself a
check for ten million dollars for acting
services rendered and I gave myself uh
five years there were three years maybe
and and I dated at Thanksgiving 1995 and
I put it in my wallet and I kept it
there and it deteriorated and
deteriorated and stuff and and but then
just before Thanksgiving 1995 I found
out that I was gonna make ten million
dollars on thinking food Dumb and Dumber
made dumb and dumber yeah I don't want
to be a an icon I want to be an idea you
know I want to represent an idea i want
to represent possibilities I want to
represent magic right that you're in a
universe in two plus two equals four two
plus two only equals four if you accept
that two plus two equals four two plus
two is going to be what I want it to be
you know and there's that there's a like
there's it there's a redemptive
power that making a choice has you know
rather than feeling like you're at a
fete to all the things that are
happening make a choice like you just
decide what it's going to be who you're
going to be how you're going to do it
just decide and then from that point the
universe is going to get out your way
it's like it's water once the it wants
to move and go around stuff you know so
for me I want to represent possibilities
I want to represent the idea that you
really can make what you want one of my
favorite books is the The Alchemist
Paulo Coelho and that's just I just
believe that I believe that I can create
whatever I want to create if I can put
put my head on it right study it learn
the patterns and you know I just I it's
hard to put into words real metaphysical
esoteric nonsense but I feel very
strongly that we are who we choose to be
I remember a time earlier my career is
about 24 and I went to do a seminar in
Boston and in those days a big seminar
for me was like 125 people it was a
three-day seminar and we worked around
the clock and people made such
extraordinary changes in their life and
at the end of it I was feeling so
fulfilled I was thinking my god on 24
maybe 25 at the time and I am so happy
because I have found my mission in life
I'm doing what I love it's making a
difference in people's lives this is
extraordinary so he finished about
midnight on the Sunday night and around
midnight you know I'm still wound up so
I don't feel like going to bed so I
decided okay you know let me take a walk
here and I would sided go through Copley
Square if you've been through Copley
Square you know it's a pretty neat place
because in Copley Square you can look up
and you can see buildings that were here
before we were known as the United
States and beside them you see
skyscrapers that are new though it's a
pretty cool place so I'm walking around
midnight on Sunday night there's nobody
in Copley Square midnight and Sunday
night and I'm walking along and I see
this guy in the distance and he's kind
of stumbling back and forth between the
cutter and the sidewalk hey the long
trench coming on his heads down like
this he's holding a brown bag and I can
start to smell him even before I get
there and I'm thinking you know this
guy's obviously drunk and as I started
get closer I thought I bet he's going to
beg me for some money
and sure enough whatever you focus on
life tends to happen doesn't it so sure
enough he gets real close to me and I
thought all sudden he wasn't going to do
it all so he popped his head up was
really rid of it mister it was really
bizarre looking sounding voice what
mister could you loan me quarter do i
pot do I want to reward this behavior
and then I thought I don't want him to
suffer do you have this dilemma
sometimes like you know I'm not here to
judge so years ago I finally decided I
always just give even the person's
pulling a scam that's for them to deal
with if I have the ability then they
give and so I thought what could I teach
him something so I asked him a question
back I said is that all you want is a
quarter he go yeah just one quarter one
quarter change my whole life
won't work that's it really so yeah
won't work
so I reached in my pocket and I pull out
my money club and those days I was you
know very young just starting to succeed
in my original mentor was a man named
Jim Rohn I don't know how many heard of
Jim Riley yeah it's a great guy
and Jim told me said Tony look you've
come from a poor background you got a
poor psychology you got to change it he
said you don't have any money to pretend
you do he said start training your brain
condition it
he said go save all your money get $300
bills and put them in the outside of
your money clip even though you only
have five bucks in between them so every
time you pull out you'll see that you'll
feel inspired you'll feel better he said
you'll feel better you'll do better so I
was like okay so I did so I pulled my
money clip and sure enough I got trained
under dollar bills so I made sure he saw
the bills so I'm tearing through that
right looking in between there see if I
can find some change
but I made sure he saw sure enough he's
looking at the hundred dollar bills
checking it out I find a quarter I pull
it out take him money put in my pocket I
notice he's watching my hand going into
the pocket I took the quarter and I
looked at him and I said sir life will
pay any price you ask of it I gave in
the quarter
and then something really interesting
happened he took the quarter he looked
at the quarter he looked at me he looked
at my pocket he looked back at the
quarter looked at me looked at my pocket
looked at me again look to the quarter
looked in my pocket looked back at me
and said you were weird and then he
shuffled on off like this right and I
thought to myself wow what's the
difference between him and me I mean I
was twenty four twenty five at the time
doing what I love most have my mission
in life and he's in his early 60s drunk
on the street begging for quarters
what's the difference and I thought well
maybe God's bless me because I'm such a
good person and he's such a bad person
that's such bull and I thought wow maybe
the answer to that question is what I
just told him life will pay whatever
price you ask of it you know what's
interesting he got to ask intelligently
and the Bible it says ask and you shall
what yeah pretty good formula you gotta
look into it but you know what it says
asking you shall receive but I'm sure it
meant ask intelligently I'm sure that's
what God meant I'm sure you didn't mean
[ __ ] and you will receive wine and you
will receive I don't think that was the
instruction now if you're gonna ask
intelligently there might be five
elements of that number one you'd have
to ask specifically wouldn't you
wouldn't ask in a general way people do
the honest I want more money fine here's
a dollar get out of here very often
you're getting what you're asking for
you're just not aware of how general
you're asking clarity is power the more
clear you are about exactly what it is
you want the more your brain knows how
to get there your brain is a
servomechanism it's like a bomb those
bombs those missiles they have a
servomechanism so if the target moves it
knows what the target is it follows it
your brain when you condition it knows
exactly what to go for it will find a
way to get there you ever buy a certain
outfit or a certain car and suddenly see
that car outfit everywhere how many grab
that experience say I how come that car
outfits everywhere it always was
everywhere but now you notice it in
reason because there's a part of your
brain called the reticular activating
system the RAS that
your brain determines what you notice
and what you don't notice your brain
spends most of its time try to make sure
you don't notice because you'll go crazy
if you notice everything but when you
decide what's most important to you your
brain goes after it
everyone I know successful have builds
what I call an RPM plan and RPM is built
on the metaphor that the way to get from
where you are to where do you want to go
to the fastest is you got to build power
like at a car rpms and the R stands for
they know the result they're after they
know what they want precisely if you
don't know exactly what you want or you
let yourself get beyond that into
something general you're not going to
achieve it
clarity is power you got to know the
specific result you have to what do you
want if you can't answer that question
right now in your personal life in your
body in your relationships and your
finances and your spirituality then
you're not going to be as fulfilled as
you want to be today we're going to have
you answer one of those questions at
least the second part of that you got to
know P why you're doing it because you
know what you may get a big goal so does
I want to make a billion dollars I want
to bring peace to the earth why because
soon as you come over the goal all the
obstacles show up unless you got enough
emotional drive to break through that
you're never going to discover what it
really takes so you got to get yourself
past that no way to get past that us
have enough reasons reasons come first
answers come second this man did not
know what he wanted you to not have
enough reasons to ask intelligently you
got to have specifically to ask
intelligent you've got to know why you
want to have enough drive to make it
happen enough juice to make it happen if
you don't have enough reasons you will
not make it happen
and the M is what is your massive action
plan what is going to get you to
actually fall through because the first
plan is not going to work and the second
one is going to work so you better have
enough plans that the first two don't
work you still got something else
otherwise you're going to be having
excuses why it didn't work so asking
intelligently requires that so if we're
going to be extraordinary in our results
we're going to be an extraordinary state
we're going to know what we want we're
going to go use it I try to share the
principle success whenever I can because
I have not gotten this far without
learning the principles of success and
over the years I've just realised that
common sense just ain't that common so I
often get inspiration from books and one
book that resonates with me all the time
is this book right here it's called the
secret it is the most powerful book
outside of the Bible that I have ever
read in my life and the book is based on
the law of attraction and how that
principle once you master it can help
you find wealth happiness better health
whatever you're looking for
relationships so let me share some of
the concepts that have helped keep me on
my game so the first one is like
attracts like you have to understand you
are a magnet whatever you are that's
what you draw to you if you're negative
you're gonna draw negativity you're
positive you draw positive you're a kind
person more people are kind to you so
you like a magnet you know and you got
to understand something about like
attracts like if you see it in your mind
you can hold it in your hand this is so
true you've got to grab this got to
create dream boards you got to put the
new car up on your mirror put the weight
you want to be on the refrigerator if
you could see it in your mind you could
hold it in your hand that's the law of
attraction that's what you bring to you
do you know that the law of attraction
is always working it's like the law of
gravity if I let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is law of
gravity anything heavier than earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attractions always
working now how does it work well I use
a diagram to explain the mind I left
this circle represent your mind and let
this little circle here represent your
body now I want you to think of this for
a moment your body is a molecular
structure this is a massive energy and a
very high speed of vibration if you
looked at your body through a microscope
you'd see that energy dancing right
before your eyes
here's something that will keep you
thinking for the next twenty years when
you move out of it the
body does not stop moving if you go to a
funeral parlor and pick up the remains
and look at it you will see it moving
and if it wasn't moving how would it
ever change the dust you move into your
body and you will move up and it's how
you use your mind that's going to
dictate the vibration you're in now stay
with me you have an imaginary line right
across here and that separates the
conscious mind from the subconscious
mind now the subconscious mind has been
programmed when you were a little baby
this is the way it was or just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there and all the energy
that went in there when you were just a
little baby form something called a
paradigm now a paradigm is information
it's a multitude of habits you are the
product of your environment but prior to
that you are the product of a genetic
strain that goes back for generations
now I'm going to say that the paradigm
is X type energy now you've got the
ability here on a conscious level to
think and you can think anything you
want to think and as you think you build
ideas there's a power that's flowing
into your consciousness it never stops
it flows to and through you you can
actually photograph this power leaving
you it flows to and through you now as
it flows in you will start thinking and
you'll probably think X Y plus therefore
you're going to be in an X type
vibration and that will produce X type
results now it's the results you want to
change and to change the results you're
going to have to change what you attract
you see the thoughts that you think
control the vibration that you're in
vibration is nothing but an idea it's a
law of the universe everything vibrates
nothing rest we live in an ocean of
motion and it's the thoughts that you're
thinking that you impress upon your
subconscious mind that control the
vibration the bodies in
and that dictates how you act but it
also dictates what you attract you
attract energy that's in harmony with
you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's an
infinite number of frequencies but you
and I operate on the frequency just like
a radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned into the vibration you're in now
it's the paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration you can change
your thinking but that doesn't do
anything you really change the paradigm
and if you don't change the paradigm
nothing happens now talking about
paradigms is another subject we will do
that at another time but it's the
thoughts that you think that control the
vibration you're in and that dictates
what you attract so if you keep
attracting what you don't want
understand this it's the paradigm that's
causing the problem
you can think a Y type thought which is
totally different than the X type
conditioning it isn't going to go
anywhere because when you go to get
emotionally involved and this is the
emotional main when you go to get
emotionally involved with that white
tape done the paradigm will kick it out
you know why it's so uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort but understand this
the paradigm and the thinking control
the vibration you're in then the
vibration areas going to dictate what
you attract people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you can gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in their results
why they're done
the law of attraction you've got to
change this you got to change the
vibration you're in and your whole world
changes listen in 1961 a man gave me
this book and he said do exactly what I
tell you he was giving me why type ideas
it caused an enormous amount of
discomfort but I did exactly what he
said
and you know something my income went
from four thousand a hundred and seventy
five thousand a year and then I took it
over a million it took me nine and a
half years to figure out what happened
this is what I'm showing you watch this
over and over and over again there's a
number of lessons in here and another
lesson I'm going to show you how to
change the paradigm when you change the
paradigm the change in results is
automatic you know what you start to
attract something new something
different and what we want to do is
program in positive information and
eliminate the negative I'm going to show
you how to do a law of attraction you
attract according to the vibration
you're in this thing we live in is a
molecular structure your body is a
massive energy you know if you put your
body in front of an infrared television
camera in a completely dark room your
whole being would be nothing but a
glistening radiating gleaming form
feeling is conscious awareness of the
vibration we're in when we don't feel
good we're in a negative vibration I
want to feel good move into a positive
vibration stop and think of what you're
grateful for but understand this you
will never attract to you wealth
happiness health until you get the
paradigm get you on that frequency thank
you guys so much for watching
for me attracting success really came
down to changing my environment creating
environment that attracts success that
that makes me think differently and
think bigger the reason why I have the
people that I do on the wall is I want
to walk in and see those faces and it
means something to the man except to
think like them and some of their
mindsets brush off on me the reason why
I have the top ten series and Ian
stresses it's a hang
around these famous entrepreneurs and
people who've done a lot and it makes me
change my mindset and I've seen so many
opportunities open up that didn't come
to me before or I wasn't paying
attention to before and now they're
suddenly coming because my mindset has
shifted I have more courage I had more
confidence I'm willing to take risk and
willing to say yes is something that I
may be afraid of where before I wasn't
doing it and that has led to a lot of
amazing things happen in my life in my
business that before wasn't happening
and so I think the environment plays a
super important role I think we are too
often subject to the environment that
are is given to us you know we just hang
around the friends you grew up with we
hang around the family that we grew up
with we don't tend to change or create
environment on purpose do things that we
want to do we don't set a goal like we
set a goal and then we just set here the
things that I need to do to accomplish
that goal here are the steps but the
steps often fall apart you don't stick
to the habit you don't actually do the
steps and often that's because your
environment sucks because you may have
had that one moment of boldness that
makes you breakout that makes you
believe in yourself that makes you want
to go do something insane and crazy and
powerful and courageous and then the
next thing you wake up and it's all gone
what's up you coming in this is Rebecca
how do you track success what do you
think very good question
caught me off guard listen listen yeah I
like doing this it's good do you have a
story about how you listened and that
attracted success for you um I think
it's about studying people story
it's always worked for me anyway I like
it on the spot I like it
have a great day Rebecca so yes your
goals fall apart because you don't have
the environment and people don't pay
enough attention to the environment and
so super important to do for you to do
whatever goal you have for yourself also
then think about what are the habits and
environment that I need to create for
myself that will support me achieving
that goal beyond just the steps that you
need to take so hopefully that helps
that's my take so thank you so much for
watching I made this video because nice
stuff asked me to so if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover in the next
edition of believe life leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do thanks again for watching I'd also
love to know which are your which of the
clips that we saw was your favorite what
left the biggest impact on you and why
leave in the comments I'll join the
discussion continue to believe and I'll
see you soon